it's going green
yet okay we're live
now
okay right let's start and uh welcome to
everybody online to the Seamus healthc
care Diagnostics keynote webinar for the
bio conference live um bio conference
live
2014 we're going to be talking about
companion Diagnostics and changing the
face of healthcare my name is Andrew
beard and I'm the senior director of the
Seaman clinical lab marketing and
companion Diagnostics and I'm going to
be the host and the facilitator of the
webinar
today
next we seem to be having some technical
issues here just pulling up the second
slide May on this second
slide
okay right okay we now we're now back in
business um I'm going to be giving a
brief introduction to everybody online
the audience online to companion
Diagnostics this will be followed up by
um two presentations by our experts here
Dr Patrick Joseph who's our medical
director of the Seaman clinical lab and
a practicing physician he's really going
to be talking about companion
diagnostics for making it personal for
patients that'll be followed by a
presentation by Dr Richard Frank who's
the chief medical officer on uh for
clinical strategy and policy for sema's
healthcare and he's going to be talking
about a bit more of the reality of the
world into which companion Diagnostics
are going to be born talking about some
of the trends in healthcare and the
impact on companion diagnostics at the
end of this presentation we'll be
finishing with a Q&A and a panel
discussion with our experts um if you
wish to submit questions to uh to our to
our to our experts on the left hand side
of your screen you should see a Q&A
button if you click that Q&A button a
text box should appear you place your
question in there that will appear on
our computers here and at the end of
this presentation we may have an
opportunity to choose your questions for
our experts to respond to okay with that
I'd just like to move on to the first
part of this presentation which really
what I'm going to be doing for the next
10 minutes or so to talk about an
introduction to companion
Diagnostics companion Diagnostics are
more than just a hypothesis it's
actually a reality of today but that's
being very much reinforced by some
primary research that we've been doing
with our customer base plus also a
number of key opinion leaders ERS around
the world we've identified five themes
that are clearly going to shape the
invitro diagnostic industry and
obviously the testing communities over
the over the next few years one of which
one of those pillars if you like or one
of those five themes has been around
Precision medicine and that's what we're
really going to be talking about today
Precision
medicine so let's start with some
terminology because it's often very
confusing um about what people mean at
least within industry we talk about
companion Diagnostics but typically when
you're working with uh pharmaceutical
Partners they also think in terms of
precision medicine at the end of the day
both more or less mean the same thing
but really they're both focused on the
patient really enabling personalized
medicine for improved patient outcomes
all that really means is that what
you're trying to do is that you're
applying tests to a population of POS
possible candidates for a therapy and
obviously applying a biomarker to those
uh to to testing those individuals and
that will result in selecting those IND
a certain number of individuals who are
most likely to respond to the therapy in
question one of the major drivers if you
like of the uh of companion Diagnostics
requirement is actually our expanding
knowledge of disease and it's increasing
by the day exponentially in many in many
cases here's an example of how
hematological malignancies were viewed
over the last 100 years starting off
with a consideration of diseases of the
blood where the 5year survival rate was
more or less zero to what we have today
where in this particular category of
diseases there may be up to 80 types of
combination of luemas and lymphomas that
You' want to be able to identify and
it's often true to say that the
therapies May well be targeted to either
individual classes of the of the disease
or in fact groups of the disease and as
you can see as far from this particular
slide over time as the therapies have
improved and how's they're going to
improve in the future the 5-year
survival rates have improved
dramatically well for for companion
Diagnostics to become a real reality
it's taken the pharmaceutical industry
some time to recognize the value of
testing alongside their therapist and
now it's actually a recognized model
within the pharmaceutical uh development
process I think the most tangible
evidence of how it how how it's been
embraced within industry is the fact
that now the vast majority of uh
pharmaceutical companies now have
dedicated organizations and resources
looking for the potential of test to be
used alongside death therapies either in
early stage development or indeed Beyond
in later stage development in some cases
and you can see a quote at the bottom of
this slide where an in this particular
case the pharmaceutical company
acknowledges that the vast majority of
their therapist in development are
indeed utilizing some kind of biomarker
if you look at specific disease states
such as oncology the adoption of
biomarkers or adoption of companion
Diagnostics can cover more or less all
the tests all the therapies that are in
development today which is fairly
impressive considering where it's come
from if you go back 20 years
ago so where are we today and I think if
you go to the FDA website um you can you
can review the number of companion
diagnostic tests that have been approved
at this moment in time there are 19
companion diagnostic uh tests and
therapy combinations that are FDA
approved
uh now this slide doesn't refer to all
of them it's just the most the most
recent approvals that have taken place
but the take-home here is that this is
effectively the tip of an iceberg we
think over the next few years this is
going to rapidly the approvals of uh
combination of companion Diagnostics and
the therapies is only going to increase
over time and hence our conclusion that
it's going to have a major a major
impact on the on the diagnostic and the
testing communities in the near future
so in the development of these companion
diagnostic tests there are opportunities
and challenges for a combination of uh
ourselves as a Diagnostics company but
also for our partners especially the
pharmaceutical partners and of course
the lab testing Community who are going
to be clearly the vehicle for for
helping realize the potential of
companion Diagnostics in the future I
won't go through all the individual
questions that are typically asked by
each of the should we say the
stakeholders in the development of these
companion diagnostic tests but they kind
of more or less condense into a few
fundamental questions some of which I
think are going to be addressed by Dr
Franks later in his presentation on on
the healthcare environment so the
typical questions that are asked across
the Partnerships what tests are use how
get how do they get used who's going to
be asking for those tests and who's
going to be asking the test when will
they be available and fundamentally
who's going to be paying for those tests
at the end of the
day so our approach the Seaman uh
Healthcare Diagnostics approach to
companion Diagnostics is graphically
represented in this in this next slide
and this is where we leverage our clear
laboratory operations based in Berkeley
California we develop essentially what
we call lab develop tests that are
analytically validated that uh are then
utilized in clinical trials and we and
we and we undertake the clinical trials
testing utilizing our clear lab
operations as as the as the as the test
are developed it obviously helps with
the the clinical validation through the
access to the clinical trials and
ideally we end up in parallel developing
diagnostic test kits that may well end
up on our on our routine platforms of
the future this diagnostic test Di ostic
test kits have access to the clinical
samples from the clinical trials and
hence they become the candidates for the
regulatory submissions and the approvals
which ultimately make the tests
available around them around the world
in in conjunction with the therapy so
that you have Optimum patient
access so my brief summary of companion
Diagnostics is represented in this next
slide it's all around clinical
excellence and and she we term it this
on this occasion Precision medicine but
it's really about the
patient where we're leveraging the best
information the best science in specific
disease
States there's the choice of technology
and platform is obviously very important
for the final deployment of those tests
for patient
access and obviously we combine all
these together to really help real
realiz the full potential of companion
Diagnostics so that's the end of my
introduction to companion Diagnostics
I'll now hand over to Dr Patrick Joseph
our uh our medical director of the
Seaman clinical lab who's going to talk
to making companion Diagnostics personal
for patients so Dr Joseph well thank you
Andrew um and thank you for the nice
introduction yeah I I have a a very
pleasant opportunity today and that is
to discuss the
emotions of Physicians and patients so
my talk or at least the the next few
minutes will be about the physician
patient interaction and my impression of
how Physicians and patients think so as
we enter this era of companion
Diagnostics and personalized medicine
I'm I'm often asked are Physicians
receptive to this or will Physicians be
a bit of an obstacle to the progression
and I think I can answer that question
today so let's let's start with the
definitions now the first definition on
on the slide in front of you where it
says generic is pretty much my verbiage
and that is it's a bioanalytical test or
any test that we might do in the
laboratory that's designed to assess
whether or not a patient will respond to
a drug
that is not the good definition or at
least the 21st century definition of a
companion
Diagnostic and I think that's better
expressed by the FDA and let me
emphasize that it is a a bioanalytical
test or a diagnostic assay that is
essential for the safe and effective use
of a drug and not only that it is often
co-marketed with the drug so that the
package P insert for the drug and the
package insert for the test support each
other meaning that the package insert of
the drug says that the companion
diagnostic must show that this drug is
likely to be effective so let me go
through some examples and try to show
where I think we are
today this is a a a uh the results of an
antibiotic susceptibility test and many
times when I talk to some of my
physician colleagues they think that of
this as a companion Diagnostic and in a
way it is but it's not what we're
talking about today and not where we're
moving to in the future there's no
question that this shows that for a
given patient who may have a ecoli
urinary tract infection based on this
simple table that cicin would be the
best but but clearly cicin is not have a
listing in its package insert that this
is essential for the patient uh to treat
a eoli urinary tract infection this just
tells us in an old way that this was a
test that was designed to help treat a
specific patient or many patients so
what I want to talk to you about is is
what Physicians are faced with when they
see a patient in the exam room and I'm
going to go through a couple of examples
to to e emphasize this
point now what's on this slide are seven
different drugs they're all of the the
same chemical class they're all used to
lower the LDL cholesterol or the bad
cholesterol and you can see the
percentage
likelihood that each one of them may
work and and many of them probably have
an average of about 30% or
40% but it's not the same
40% so another way of saying that is is
one drug might work for one patient and
a different drug might work for another
patient but you don't know going into
that and this is a problem both for
Physicians and patients and now it's
also a problem for healthc care
providers or payers so many times what
payers will say and and probably
appropriately so let's start off with
the one that is most economical with the
fewest side effects and if that doesn't
work we'll stop that then we'll go to a
next drug and if that doesn't work we'll
stop it and we'll try another drug and
this is the practice of Medicine every
day in a physician's office so you can
imagine what we're doing many times
we're giving patients a drug that
doesn't work and they may be subject
only to side effects but we just don't
know that so this is a problem and then
there's the paperwork side of it that
Physicians often complain about and I
don't blame them to in order to give a
drug that is not covered by a particular
patients's insurance plan or coverage
often requires additional paperwork and
although it's understandable this is a
problem that we have to deal with every
day now the next slide is even more
dramatic now I I know that many times
when when a speaker presents a slide
like this here she will apologize for
the complexity and I'm not going to this
slide is one that I wanted to show
because of its
complexity this is a flowchart for the
management of parkinsonism or
Parkinson's disease as of one month ago
that is as of April
2014 this is how a physician treats a
patient with
parkinsonism and if I were just to go
down the the flow chart on the left side
once a diagnosis of parkinsonism is made
and bear with me for just a few moments
what you see in front of you is the
first thing that a physician will pick
is either an anti-cholinergic agent or a
beta blocker and then see how a patient
does and if they don't do well enough
then you can add or change to a dopamine
Agonist and then further down if that
doesn't work you can add levodopa or
change that or stop the beta blocker and
if that doesn't work often you add a
drug called claman and this is what one
has to do today now wouldn't it be
wonderful if a patient was diagnosed
with Parkinson's disease and there was a
diagnostic test that could be done that
would say for that patient this is the
drug you want to use and that's what a
companion diagnostic is not only that as
a new drug is developed for Parkinson's
Disease simultaneously with it a
diagnostic assay is designed to predict
which patients would have a beneficial
response so let's take a look at some
examples
now this is an example of going
backwards using a diagnostic test to
predict the response or lack of response
of a therapeutic agent in Colon cancers
there are several genes that are
classified as mismatch repair genes and
they express a protein the expression of
that protein can be measured using IHC
or whether or not that protein is is
expressed can also be done by PCR or
sequencing if a patient has colon cancer
and does not express those mismatch
repair proteins that is the genes aren't
active those patients don't respond to
chemotherapy which means that you don't
want to give those patients chemotherapy
it's giving chemotherapy
unnecessarily now this is an example of
a companion diagnostic that predicts
that a drug doesn't work for a drug that
was produced a long time ago and now
let's move into the 21st
century
this this is a slide that Andrew showed
earlier and I want to just use a couple
of examples in the middle of the slide
at the bottom is identified a drug named
Zori or the generic name is
kotan thori is a drug which works in
about
5% of patients with lung cancer but it
works very well in those
5% so patients with a certain kind of
lung cancer can have a diagnostic a
assay looking for rearrangement of the
AL Gene using an IHC imunohistochemistry
and for those patients who have it it's
only 5% but they have an excellent
response to this
drug that is a companion diagnostic the
the IHC assay specifies zal Cori in in
the diagnostic assay in the ivd and zal
Cori specifies the assay in the package
insert another example that that all of
you may be more familiar with are the
diagnostic tests for overexpression of
the her to new Gene in breast cancer
about 15% of patients with breast cancer
men and women will have overexpression
of the her to new
Gene and this can be diagnosed either by
IHC or by fish and if there is
overexpression of that Gene then those
patients respond to herceptin or tusab
and again in the trastuzamab
FDA P package insert it specifies that
one of these assays should be used to
detect overexpression and vice versa and
they are launched if not on the same day
within months of each other so this is
where Physicians are looking for help so
what I'm asked do
Physicians be re will Physicians be
receptable to this concept and do
Physicians like the concept of companion
Diagnostics the answer is is
overwhelming and it's emphasized on this
slide no patient wants to receive
ineffective therapy I can tell you that
from the patients I see in my office and
I can give you my perspective that no
doctor wants to prescribe it and what we
can say that is coming in the future is
a better solution that is companion
Diagnostics thank you I'm going to turn
it back over to Andrew okay thank you
very much um uh Dr Joseph we're now
going to switch gears and we're going to
pass it over pass the Baton over to Dr
Frank who as I mentioned before is our
chief medical officer uh in Seaman
Healthcare and uh Dr Frank is going to
talk about the US Healthcare environment
the challenges and opportunities for
companion Diagnostics Dr Frank thanks
Andrew I'm grateful for this opportunity
to share with you some of our thinking
about the changes in the delivery of
Healthcare in the United States and the
opportunity that that represents for
companion
Diagnostics the providers of healthc
care in the United States are facing a
number of pressures or what is described
on this slide as macro Trends and
they're responding they're reacting to
those Trends in a number of ways my
following few slides will go into some
more granularity on each one of these
but I'll just summarize Now by saying
there are demographic changes in the
United States there obviously changes in
expenditures for healthcare uh consumers
that is the patients are taking on
increased liability and by that I don't
mean legal liability I mean liability
for the their own health care costs and
finally there are a number of government
mandates which bring more pressure to
bear on the providers and their
responses are
manifold um there's consolidation that
would be mergers and acquisition
activity among hospitals and other care
providers they're economizing um both in
capital expenditures and in Opera in
expenditures um they're embarking on new
Investments not just m&a but other
Investments as well to prepare for the
future uh and finally they're preparing
primarily for a transition from fee for
service to fee for value and ultimately
perhaps something like
capitation now in this slide there's a
lot more granularity I won't talk you
through each one of these uh but on the
left we see a more detailed version of
those macro Trends and on the right a
more detailed version of the provider
reactions and the main point of this
slide which will be available to you on
the on the website later for more
detailed review uh the main point of
this slide is among these macro Trends
there are a couple such as the
demographics and the Affordable Care Act
which will tend to have a favorable
impact on the demand for Health Care uh
and yet you see that these are yellow
rather than green uh because they're not
unmit at favorable impacts and all the
rest of the trends such as the trend in
National Health Care expenditure are
actually downward and represent
pressures on the providers which is
leading to the reactions that you see
listed on the right such as
consolidation among Hospital delivery
networks the economizing to which I
referred uh earlier but also innovation
in the delivery of health care which
likely will have a beneficial effect
such as reaching out into the community
for things like um obesity and smoking
and so on so as we consider more
granularity and what these Trends um
represent you see on the left hand side
here uh the population or demographic
trend and what you see is actually three
components here one of them is the
overall growth in the population so
there's an upward Trend in the total
size of the
population um but in particular you see
that top bar is the people in the older
the 65 and over age group um not only
are the Baby Boomers now coming into the
65 and older age group so there are more
and more people in that category uh but
also the people once they achieve the
age of 65 are living longer and
therefore there are these three Trends
the overall growth in the
population uh the growth in people
achieving the age of 65 and their
longevity at the from the age of 65 are
leading to increasing demand because the
older population have a greater
utilization of healthc care resources in
particular procedures including
Diagnostics on the right hand side you
see this boil down into the impact on
procedure volume which includes all
Diagnostics in particular in vitro
Diagnostics and including companion
Diagnostics and you see our estimate by
2020 is at the low end a 10% increase in
demand and at the high end a 20% %
increase and that's across all
procedures for inv vitro Diagnostics
particularly relevant to you um we're
estimating something approximately in
the middle of that range so about 15%
growth uh in demand for the the services
that you
provide now on this slide we see another
one of the macro Trends which is the
National Health expenditure uh in the
chart on the left the Blue Line the one
at the toward the upper end of the graph
represents the expenditures uh for
health care and you can see that the the
4.2% figure which is the current spend
has been considered quite a victory as a
significant reduction from 7% in recent
years uh but there are two key points
there one of them is it's unlikely to
remain as low as 4% it probably will
grow again to 6% or so perom in the not
too distant future uh but the other even
more important point is that even at 4%
the growth in National Health
expenditure is greater than the growth
in the gross domestic product and
therefore our spend on Health Care has
been outstripping the growth of wealth
in the country and therefore uh there
are responses to this and sort of back
pressure on on the National Health
expenditure um the graph of the on the
right is intended to translate that four
or 6% per anom growth in in healthcare
expenditure into a compound annual
growth rate so lest you think that four
or 6% isn't really very much um in fact
as a as a kager the compound annual
growth rate you can see that this leads
from uh 2 point uh plus two plus
trillion dollars uh today to over4
trillion dollar uh by 2020 and therefore
this is uh really a much bigger number
than one might have guessed uh and this
is driving behavior not only by on the
part of U public payers like Medicare uh
but also private
insurers now in this slide is portrayed
another important shift you remember I
mentioned liability on the part of the
consumers or you and me uh Employers in
particular are shifting the cost burden
to employees in a couple ways one of
them by offering High deductible plans
and so in an effort to control their own
personal costs under high deductible
circumstances the individual patients
may choose uh to access health care less
than they had in the past certainly be
more judicious uh in that process and in
the central uh box you see on this slide
you see that uh employers are also
adopting what's called um defined
contribution plans which means rather
than providing the health care as part
of the compensation package they provide
a certain dollar amount uh for the
employee then to use in buying healthc
Care on their own and so in the in the
right hand column you see a summary of
these Trends and the net effect here is
for the employers to be pushing on to
their employees uh responsibility for
their own care which will affect the
decision- making by individual
patients now this slide refers to the
thinking of the providers remember we
talked about macro Trends and how the
providers are reacting to those macro
Trends um these are two surveys of the
the sea sues in hospital networks where
they're making decisions about
Investments and in the left hand the bar
chart you can see from left to right um
the predictions for investments into the
future and on the leftand side you see
only 2% uh believe that they will
increase their investment by 25% or more
and in the right hand half of the graph
you see that more than 65% believe that
they will either not increase or will
decrease by as much as
25% uh their investment and in the right
hand box on this slide you can see part
of the reason for that when um when
they're asked in a forced ranking uh
survey to say what are the most
important things driving their behavior
in investment you can see Financial
challenges at the top of the list now
we're happy to see second on the list is
um patient safety and quality um and
this is an important driver uh for the
incorporation of of Diagnostics to
ensure patients remain um to receive
good quality Health Care uh despite the
financial challenges uh you'll also see
kind of sneaking onto this list
population Health Management uh and this
is something to which I alluded earlier
um as providers take on more and more
risk uh in providing Health Care uh it's
becoming clear to to them that helping
uh their their covered lives shall we
say uh the people in their their Network
um to um to reduce their weight uh to
stop smoking to manage other risk
factors now is actually in the interest
not only of the individual patient but
also in the interest of the provider in
order to reduce the demand for health
care now this slide is intended to
portray the shift from fee for service
uh as Healthcare has been in the United
States these many years to fee for Value
as we anticipate in fact is already
happening and it remains an open
question how rapidly there will be this
transition uh and we continue to monitor
that um but the fact is that transition
is occurring and it amounts to a shift
from primarily where under feif for
service that the volume of services is
incented because the people are paid for
each uh service that's Prov provided and
under these circumstances Diagnostics
such as Imaging and other testing
including companion Diagnostics
represent profit centers and under these
circumstances it is a sort of a nice to
have in the future under the feif for
Value circumstances then volume is
actually disincentive uh Imaging and and
other diagnostic tests uh become cost
centers uh and it is a key enabler for
this in order to ensure optimal use of
healthc Care Resources uh for good
outcomes and so under these
circumstances of shifting from fee for
service to fee for Value um the
potential the Temptation will be simply
to limit access to reduce the number of
procedures being offered to the patient
uh in order to manage the provider's uh
cost base uh but we're quite confident
that the the deliverers of healthcare
will continue to see that the
appropriate use of diag agnostics is
actually an efficiency in order to make
the best choice of therapy not only for
the best outcome for the patient but
also for the most efficient use of
Hospital resources for example getting
people out of the hospital sooner um
back to work sooner which is in the
interest of their employers and also
reducing the rate of rehospitalizations
so we're quite confident that under even
under the fee for Value circumstance um
that U certainly in the medium and long
term there will see there will be seen
value in Optimum use of
Diagnostics now on this slide um there
is a very important concept U of driving
the behavior of providers and that is
the risk that they're taking in um in
the payments that they receive from for
example Medicare on the left the bar
charts on the left indicate the um the
combined effect of a number of incentive
programs that Medicare have established
one the value based payment um others
having to do with rehospitalization and
Hospital acquired infections now the
amount of reimbursement from Medicare
which is at risk for these quality
measures uh is shall we say only
6% and yet how important is this to the
hospital that the the importance of this
to the hospital becomes clear when you
understand that fully onethird of a
Hospital's revenue is derived from
Medicare patients on average um and if
6% um of that is at risk um that's fully
2% of the hospital's Revenue uh
hospitals make about 6% profits on
average and so you can easily see that
2% uh is a third of 6% and therefore
fully onethird of a Hospital's profit is
at risk as a result of these incentive
programs from CMS and therefore they're
very much driven uh to deliver quality
and are changing the way they deliver
Health Care in order to ensure that they
get those payments in the right hand
chart you see the additional effect um
by which CMS is catalyzing a broader
payment reform the shift from fee for
service to fee for value by way of the
accountable care organizations
represented by the gray uh bars on the
left and also bundled payments which you
see in that um the Blue Bar just second
from the right uh a bundling of payments
means that things that commonly are
offered together in the hospital whether
it's a a a procedure a service or or a
therapeutic intervention those things
can be paid in a bundle uh and therefore
the hospital is incented to be efficient
in choosing perhaps the lower cost item
among those or even leaving some of
those procedures out and so it is a very
very important way for CMS by bundling
uh to shift the risk to the providers
and it's up to the providers to ensure
that they continue to deliver quality of
care not simply restrict access in order
to save
money now this slide captures some of
the demographic changes but from the
perspective of
insurance um we all hear in the news
quite frequently now about the impact of
the Affordable Care Act um and there are
two components to that that suggest in
the long run there'll be an increase in
the number of insured patients by about
25 million which is the the top line on
this chart on the left that comprises
two components one of them is expansion
of patients eligible for Medicaid which
is a decision on a state byst state
basis and the other is the people who
are buying insurance on the health
exchanges and I'll address each of those
separately patient eligibility for
Medicaid is defined by the states and
historically has been two times the
federal poverty limit what the
Affordable Care Act proposed was that
states should change that definition to
four times the federal poverty level and
some states have chosen to do that other
states have chosen not to and some
states are still deciding so whereas the
total impact might have been 12 million
it probably will be well it certainly
will be something less than that because
some of the states have decided not to
expand uh Medicare in their states and
yet there still will be many millions of
uh additional insured uh Medicaid
patients uh addressing the exchanges
we've heard these numbers quite a bit in
the news lately and I think the numbers
um probably are a little smaller than
what we hear for a couple reasons one is
not everyone who signs up actually pays
their um makes their payment and and
therefore are do not effectively get
coverage uh and also some of the people
were covered before so they don't
actually represent uh new newly insured
patients even with those caveats once
again there'll be Millions more patients
who are covered and this represents an
increase in Revenue opportunities for
the hospitals what you see in the right
hand column here is the anticipated
impact of that increased insured
population on procedure volume and it
will grow over the next few years as
more and more people come under Medicaid
or gain insurance through the exchanges
um but we think an equilibrium will be
achieved in the next few years and that
will be somewhere between an increase of
5 and 10% in demand for procedure volume
so in addition to the demographic uh
Trend we saw earlier there is this
additional um impact of increased uh
insurance right now we think that um as
regards the specific um specifics of
Diagnostics uh that it's important to
understand the benefit of early and
accurate diagnosis for the overall
impact on the better outcome for
patients but also efficient use of
Hospital resources and so we we Define
early as early relative to the rate of
progression of the disease or early
relative to the intensity of the therapy
involved and in general a disease which
is identified earlier uh can be treated
more effectively at lower cost at lower
intensity of intervention and at sooner
resolution and so the value of that
early detection uh is seen not only by
the patient but also by the hospital
delivery system by accuracy we mean uh
that the caregiver has confidence in the
ideology and and therefore the patient
management decisions that they would B
that they would make based on that uh
that
ideology and by diagnosis of course we
mean the label for the pathophysiology
which informs that choice of therapy and
ultimately Downstream coordination of
care and an important component of this
is staging which is helping to
characterize the particular
um progression of that U of that
pathophysiology in order to inform the
best choice of therapy and cancer is the
most obvious one um the decision about
which chemotherapy to apply depends in
part on the presence or absence of
metastases and we use staging most
commonly in that regard but really in
many diseases in order to make the best
choice of therapy um using Diagnostics
in order to not only identify that the
patient has the disease but to
characterize it for the state of the
pathophysiology is crucial to making the
best choice of
treatment now Dr Joseph earlier referred
to the parallel development of an
experimental therapeutic uh and the
companion Diagnostic and this chart is
from a publication of mine uh which
first appeared in nature reviews and
Drug development in 2003 and was updated
in 2011 you see the bibliographic
reference at the bottom of the slide and
as it Cascades from the upper left to
the lower right this chart um represents
phase one two and three development of
an experimental therapeutic um and at
those stages what will become a
diagnostic is considered a biomarker
it's used to stratify the population uh
and perhaps also to measure the response
to the experimental therapeutic
and then once this clinical evidence is
gathered during this uh research and
development phase and is presented to
the FDA the evidence um can support not
only the approval of the therapeutic uh
for its response and a
well-characterized population but the
same clinical evidence supporting the
role for the diagnostic uh for the
biomarker come diagnostic uh so that
there is this sort of coordinated
labeling uh to provide instructions to
Physicians about how best to prescribe
the drug based in part on the um the
results from the use of that companion
diagnostic
so there are a number of implications
for this um new way of developing drugs
and the Food and Drug Administration
have recognized that um the definitions
you see on this slide derived from the U
the FDA and you can see the link there
in the bottom of the slide the main
point here is is that FDA recognize that
this is the wave of the future and
they're preparing uh the regulatory
infrastructure and Pathways necessary to
do a good job of ensuring safety and
efficacy U not only to protect the
American public but also to Foster
better
medicine uh in a little more granularity
um the FDA policy has been stated U that
it is essential for the safe and
effective use of a corresponding
therapeutic product and they have issued
issued a guidance uh in draft form uh
which we would Advocate being issued in
final form uh with a number of things
being addressed in order to optimize
this regulatory Pathway to ensure not
only safety and efficacy but also
minimize the risk of such a burdensome
regulatory process that it would
effectively um block uh new products
from coming into the market in the
United States and and I should add that
um because of the good coordination with
regulatory aenc genes worldwide we fully
expect that progress in the United
States would soon be followed in Europe
as
well so we see this as
um not only a regulatory opportunity to
optimize bringing new products into the
marketplace but also an opportunity to
get coverage and payment jointly known
as
reimbursement um uh to get that
optimized as well because it's important
for private insurers and for uh CMS or
Medicare and Medicaid uh to cover these
appropriately and so as they bundle or
another word is packaging so that
they're making one payment for a bundle
of procedures and treatments and so on
um these should not inadvertently
disincentivize investment in novel
Diagnostics by the payments being too
low but instead uh there should be
rewards for innovation in the
development of companion Diagnostics
because of the prospect for improved
outcomes and overall efficiency in the
delivery of Health Care um another
recent Factor um is The Clinical
Laboratory fee schedule reform it's it's
uncertain what the impact of this will
be but it's clear that CMS intend to pay
a weighted average of private sector
prices beginning in
2017 uh and so there will need to be
some rul making for the Fuller
implementation of this this new law and
we look forward to having a favorable
impact on that so that it's realistic uh
both in its implementation and in its
evaluation
ation we think that coverage for
companion Diagnostics uh should be with
immediate effect from FDA approval
because the fda's review of safety and
efficacy should be adequate for the
purpose of determining that this is
reasonable and necessary and
specifically the cross-labeling of the
diagnostic with the therapeutic should
make it clear that the use of that
diagnostic is not only reasonable but is
necessary for the appropriate use of
that therapeutic and then finally
appropriate use criteria you've probably
heard a lot about recently uh because
this is the manifestation of
evidence-based medicine uh it's good
medicine uh and if derived from the
clinical evidence that was generated by
the the development of the experimental
therapeutic clearly showing the role for
what had been a biomarker doing R&D and
now as a diagnostic as a companion to
the therapeutic we're it's quite clear
that this would be an appropriate use
for
that and so with that I'll just
summarize by saying that companion
Diagnostics offer the prospect for
better outcomes for the patient which
can be achieved with greater efficiency
for the Health Care system and we're
quite confident that this is the way of
the future thank
you okay Dr Frank thank you very much
for that insight into the uh into the
healthcare World here in the United
States we're now going to move into a
panel discussion and a Q&A at which uh
in which people can present their
questions for Dr Franks and Dr Joseph I
think on your on your screens on the
left hand side you should see a little
button called Q&A if you have any
questions please put your questions into
the Q&A text box and we will receive
them over here and uh we'll be in a
position to pose those questions to our
experts and we've got uh a few minutes
left before we get to the hour so uh
please start to submit your questions uh
as soon as you can so so um what I'd
like to do is uh we've got one or two
questions here already that perhaps
you'd like to comment on um one is um
you know in the audience there's going
to be obviously it's it's majority of
the folks here are the lab testing
Community we've got lab directors there
and I'm sure they must be asking
themselves these kinds of questions
about well you know there are a number
of companion diagnostic tests out there
today there'll be many more on the
Horizon through obviously the work
that's going on right now with the
alignment of the the the um say the the
test development programs and the
therapy development programs you know
how are they going to deal with
situations where potentially the therapy
is available the test is actually
available and yet it may be
inadequately reimbursed so do you have
any thoughts on that perhaps Dr Frank
yes I alluded to this somewhat in my
formal remarks the concern is that um as
hospitals face the financial reality of
trying to sustain what amounts to a
business uh in the face of so many
Financial pressures the the the
Temptation will be simply to take cost
out by by providing fewer services and
and using Diagnostics um less um we're
quite confident that in the long run
they will see that the the use of
companion Diagnostics is not only good
for the patient but also good for
efficient use of healthcare resources in
their hospitals and yet in the short run
there may be this risk of limited access
and I think for the individual
caregiver uh who is here not so much
operating a business but is here to
provide medical care they will continue
to take a patient centered approach to
this they know what's best for the
patient they are effectively advocates
for the
patient um and it's incumbent upon each
of us to to advocate for that patient by
choosing the right diagnostic tests in
order to make the best therapeutic
decision for them and if that results in
um some cost pressures on the hospital
Network because the payments are
inadequate for that they should not be
bashful in raising that issue uh with
the payers whether private or public so
I think um there this tension is very
likely in the coming years I think the
patient centered approach makes it
incumbent upon us to continue to provide
the the services and the treatments that
the patients need uh but that we can't
be bashful about flagging up to those
who are making the the payment decisions
of the essential nature of these
services and the inadequacy of the
payments and effectively fight that
corner not only on behalf of the the
sustainability of the business of
delivering health care but ultimately on
behalf of the patients as well okay and
uh Richard let me ask you from our
previous discussion
and when you've talked about this in
your experience some of these companion
Diagnostics may be very very expensive
and I don't mean the charge I mean the
cost of doing the test can be very
expensive and of course the concern is
that the reimbursement will be less than
the cost but if this test is run and
let's assume that we're dealing with a a
an a Medicaid
beneficiary if this test is run on all
patients with a given
disease can't that be presented to the
FDA in a way that this really is driving
value meaning we're determining which
patients to treat and more importantly
which patients not to treat with
expensive drugs and in your experience
is that a legitimate argument uh for
getting better
reimbursement well certainly yes the
short answer is yes the the longer
answer is that that the clinical
evidence to support that argument comes
from the the parallel development of the
therapeutic and the diagnostic and the
R&D for the experimental agent and so as
FDA have approved that the safety and
efficacy of that the essential nature of
the diagnostic as a companion to the
therapeutic is clear part of what FDA
will have done is reviewed the the
response rate uh and for those who have
a positive result on the test as
compared to the response rate the
negative people that have negative
results on the test and that's the basis
for approval so the value of the test is
as you've alluded identifying patients
who are likely to respond and therefore
the value of that therapeutic to them is
greater uh and you've also avoided then
the unnecessary expense of treating
patients who won't benefit from it and
beyond that it's not just a matter of
expense most drugs have some adverse
effects and patients have varying
susceptibility to that uh but even the
small susceptibility even the relatively
minor adverse effect uh is something
that a patient shouldn't suffer if they
have no likelihood of response to the uh
to the treatment so it's not only a
matter of saving money by not treating
patients who won't benefit from the drug
it's also a matter of saving them
exposure to the risk of the adverse
effect so there's value not only for the
patients who are have a positive result
to the test therefore we know we're more
likely to respond but there's also value
to the patients who might be put at
unnecessary risk of adverse effects
thank you okay thank you very much for
that response uh we're getting a number
of good questions coming in here so uh I
do apologize to those folks who are
submitting the questions I'm going to
somewhat paraphrase them in the interest
of time got a question here is actually
talking about complimentary
Diagnostics now we talk about companion
Diagnostics but are they really you this
maybe goes to the overall definition of
what a companion diagnostic test is all
about are they really
diagnostic well I'll I'll deal with that
Jo if you can answer that one the term
diagnostic has many definitions and
those of us who who also work in the
laboratory have a tendency to use the
term
Diagnostics as any test we run or any
analyte and really it's it is a
diagnostic assay but it's not diagnosing
a disease it's it's defining a patient's
result so a diagnostic may be an
electrolyte panel but that's not
necessarily diagnosing a
disease as as was pointed out so well
earlier by Richard a companion
diagnostic has a very specific
definition from the Food and Drug
Administration and that is it is a test
that is essential for the safe and
effective use of a drug and if I could
expand on that a little bit I think um
what Patrick says is perfectly right um
in many cases what we call a diagnostic
test such as for an electrolyte or
glucose or something is not actually
making a diagnosis it's detecting
something which becomes a component of a
diagnosis yeah and so I often use the
word detection rather than diagnosis to
describe what we're doing um at the
other end the use of a companion
diagnostic is actually higher value even
than the diagnostic I would use the word
prognostic because it's telling us what
is the likelihood of response to a
particular treatment and if we know that
it's more likely that this patient will
respond to this treatment that gives it
greater value uh and that's actually
making a prognosis for what the course
of disease is likely to be in this
patient uh as in particular as treated
with that particular drug so at the
front end you have what we call
diagnostic tests which are really just
detecting something and they need to be
taken in a much broader context of all
the other components that lead to a
diagnostic at the other end you have a
very high value companion diagnostic
which is really leading directly to the
choice of a therapy that's very likely
more likely to be beneficial for that
patient okay thank you okay we've got uh
a question here uh which is quite
operational in in terms of how it's how
it's pitched but it's it's about when
you introduce these companion diagnostic
test
are often new to the testing community
so the question is you know first
question is who provides the test but I
think perhaps more importantly is what's
the view in terms of the the quality
assurance the proficiency testing of
these kinds of new to Market or new to
the testing Community type tests that's
kind of maybe Dr Jose you may have some
views on proficiency testing for these
these kinds of of new tests well we we
should go through the sequence
considering uh the audience for this
webinar uh the sequence that is typical
as a drug is being developed if a
biomarker is thought to be predictive
for the successful use of a new drug
then typically a laboratory developed
test is the companion diagnostic to it
and so that has to be developed in a
laboratory that has the a the ability to
generate and
ldt and when the first thing that
happens of course that most people know
is that we do analytical validation we
have to determine the accuracy and the
Precision and in order to do that
perhaps make internal proficiency
testing controls right that's the first
step so we've got a test that's
reproducible that's relatively accurate
that's got proficiency testing then as
one moves forward with the usually the
pharmaceutical company developing the
drug then there is clinical
validation so we start off with
analytical validation then clinical
validation on clinical trials and if
those are successful then the next steps
that we have seen in the past are to
commercialize that assay and turn it
hopefully into an FDA approved kit that
can be disseminated to Laboratories
around the
world okay thank you um we've got other
couple of questions popping up here now
I know that we've focused on on
obviously the US perspective on
companion Diagnostics certainly the
regulatory side of it I think Dr Frank
you mentioned that what do we know about
what's happening you know in other parts
of the world for companion
Diagnostics well in the United States
there's been a a draft guidance which we
would Advocate being finalized with the
additional points as you saw in my slide
um we think that the Europeans are
prepared also to um to modernize their
regulations around this to tidy up and
and prepare for this future in which
there more and more of these these tests
with the sort of sophistication and
validation and so so on to which Dr
Joseph just referred and so we
anticipate in the next couple years that
just as in the United States so also in
Europe will there be um an enhanced
sophistication in the regulatory pathway
which on the one hand will enhance the
likelihood of quality and safety and
efficacy and on the other hand not
create such a burdensome pathway that
these products can't become available to
patients okay thank you well um
unfortunately we've got a couple more
questions here but I don't believe we've
got sufficient time to complete them
because we're about one minute from the
end of the hour so I think it's Pro for
those folks who've actually submitted
additional questions we will try and
respond to those offline through our
experts uh but given we're so close
close to the hour what I'd like to do is
draw this uh webinar to a close so on
behalf of uh of seus healthcare
Diagnostics I'd like to thank our
speakers very much for participating in
this event and for their contributions
but I should also like to reach out to
the online audience also for setting
aside their valuable time to listen to
this webinar today um thank you very
much for your attendance and if you wish
to follow with more information on what
we do Sean Healthcare Diagnostics in the
companion diagnostic space you'll see on
this final slide a URL that you can go
to and it gives some details around our
interests in this space so thank you
very much to everybody for participation
for listening to us we wish everybody a
great day and we will say goodbye thank
you thank you thank
you